the winter blast is whipping across the
country barreling through the Rockies
causing near whiteout conditions for
drivers in Utah Downing trees and
knocking out power lines along the west
coast snow piled onto this highway in
Idaho in just hours
the Blizzard's Bullseye is now over
Minneapolis we are bracing for what is
likely to be one of the largest
snowstorms in Minnesota History the
National Weather Service is predicting
up to 45 mile per hour winds and
difficult or even impossible driving
conditions for travelers
Minneapolis-St Paul Airport a major
Delta Hub is bracing for the possibility
of widespread cancellations most
Airlines here have waived cancellation
and change fees